minor spoilers for Strange World ahead
unusual names notable diversity and an
important call to protect the planet
here are some of the things only adults
noticed in Disney's Strange World
Strange World the latest theatrical
release from Disney's Animation Studios
follows Jaeger clade a legendary
Explorer from avalonia a lands that is
surrounded by mountains on all sides on
his greatest journey to finally see
beyond the mountains his son Sergio
discovers a new substance that becomes
the land's greatest power source however
Jaeger doesn't make it back from the
Expedition years later Searcher lives on
a farm with his son Ethan and wife
Meridian however it soon transpires that
the substance search had discovered
years ago is dying and needs to be saved
searcher's family are swept away on an
adventure that leads them to a strange
World underneath avalonia full of alien
creatures and the missing Jaeger Strange
World isn't afraid to wear its genre
influences on its sleeve right from the
start the movie's love of Pop comics and
adventure stories shines in the form of
visual homage in the intro to Strange
World the credit sequence begins in
black and white before showing the cover
of an old-school style comic featuring
all the characters of the clade family
it continues in his comic book style as
the introduction sets up the prequel to
The Story beginning with jaeger clade's
Expedition Pulp Fiction refers to cheap
campy Adventure Comics published in the
first half of the 20th century up until
the 1950s the movie's directors have
even revealed that pop magazines are one
of the main influences on Strange World
drawing a press day for the film
co-director and writer Qui Quinn
revealed via what's on Disney plus
Jaeger is our pulp hero he's like one of
those guys on the covers who wear white
shirts that were ripped fighting an
alligator
Gabrielle Union gives an excellent
performance as mother wife and
adventurer Meridian clade and Strange
World Meridian is a strong supporting
character acting as a rock for both
husband Searcher and Son Ethan and she
even gets to save them from time to time
but her character and specifically her
name has a deeper meaning that
reinforces her role in the movie
[Music]
Meridian is not necessarily a common
name but it is an intentional choice
that makes sense for the character Avid
geographers will know that Meridian is
an astronomical and geographical term
used by explorers and adventurers which
refers to a line of longitude the prime
meridian for instance is a center line
where longitude is zero degrees in the
movie Meridian assertion Center as she
grounds him additionally while he lives
his life as a farmer there is a small
reluctant part of Searcher that wants to
be an Explorer the fact that his wife's
name is a geographical term is seemingly
another clue that he subconsciously
Longs for adventure
the biggest scene that runs throughout
strange world is the intergenerational
conflict between Fathers and Sons both
Diego and serger and serger and Ethan
have their own issues communicating and
connecting with one another in fact
searcher's relationship with his son is
informed by how his father treated him
which touches on the theme of
generational trauma however Strange
World also has a sense of how
male-centric the story might seem and it
Endeavors to prioritize its female
characters Jaeger Sergio and Ethan find
themselves running from some angry
wildlife and they find themselves
scrambling through the Flora and Fauna
luckily Meridian and president Mal show
up just in time to rescue them from
turning into alien food in this moment
the women of strange world have an
opportunity to shine is this thing
dangerous
in Strange World Alan tudek voices
secutes and gelatinous splat the blue
blob is one of two playful companions in
the movie The Other being the clade's
adorable three-legged Pooch Legend
Disney regularly includes cute and
cuddly companions in his animated movies
and at younger audiences and strange
world even acknowledges and pokes fun at
this practice at one point in the movie
a member of the crew noticed a Splat for
the first time and freaks out getting
very excited even points to Splat and
says it's so cute I want to merchandise
it this joke might go over the heads of
the film's younger audience but Disney's
practice of creating cute characters in
order to sell toys is well documented in
everything from Strange World to Star
Wars in Strange World each of the three
clayed men take Journeys to find
acceptance and peace with their family
in a multi-layered hero's journey the
movie focuses most on Ethan the youngest
character and the most relatable to a
young diverse audience Ethan struggles
with breaking out of the bugs that his
father is forcing him into and refuge
users to accept a future as a farmer
instead Ethan longs to be an Explorer
like his long-loster grandfather so when
the two finally meet at long last and
get to know each other they hit it off
extremely well a strange World continues
it becomes clear that Ethan resembles
his grandfather and naturally takes on
some of his mannerisms there's even a
moment on the airstrip during which
Ethan and Jaeger stand next to one
another and they hold themselves in the
exact same pose with their hands on
their hips front foot outward and ready
to Take On The World the pose itself
emphasizes The Adventurous spirit that
the two share it is a quick moment and
its significance is easy to miss but
this theme is reinforced throughout the
movie as Ethan takes after several other
characters as well Jaeger isn't the only
Fundy member Ethan has inherited traits
and mannerisms from drawing Strange
World it becomes clear that Ethan's
mother Meridian has also inspired many
of her son's traits from their need for
conversation to the way they stand Ethan
and Meridian share many similarities
Ethan shared traits with his mother and
grandfather only highlights how much
distance Ethan feels from his dad
Searcher for instance throughout the
movie Ethan goes to everyone for help
except for his dad on the surface Ethan
seems to be more like Jaeger and
Meridian than his own father and search
here is painfully aware of this fact and
becomes hopelessly fixated on it but
it's not until the final act that both
Father and Son realize what they truly
have in common I'm not my father
meanwhile search's relationship with his
own father is challenging plus that
rocky relationship didn't get any better
when Jaeger abandoned him and took off
without warning it takes most of the
movie for them to reconcile but serger
and his father eventually start to set
aside their differences and warm up to
one another they eventually spend some
time hanging out together and start to
bond after the longest time apart the
difficulties they face will be relatable
to anyone who has ever fallen out with a
family member or long to bond with a
distant parent or relative
at the start of the movie Ethan's Crush
stops by and drops off a new card for a
game called Primal Outpost at first it
looks as though Primal outposts may
share some similarities with magic the
Gathering but it's not magic that Primal
Outpost looks most similar to when it's
later played on the Airship instead
there's actually another popular board
game that Primal Outpost seems to be
both paying homage to and criticizing a
setup for Primal Outpost is title based
and the objective of the game is to gain
and trade resources while watching the
movie it's easy to see that strange
world is evoking Settlers of Catan one
of the most popular strategy board games
of all time while the collectible card
game elements and some of the in-game
rules stray from what players can do in
Catan Primal Outpost definitely feels
like a commentary on that game in
particular much of this critical
commentary comes from Ethan that's
Jaeger and Searcher argue about how to
fight in the game Ethan gets
increasingly frustrated He suggests that
the point of Primal Outpost is to use
your resources to Build a Better World
which is the exact opposite of the
colony this fantasy of Catan and games
of its ilk
by the Final Act has become increasingly
obvious that President Mal and Searcher
aren't on the right as Ethan bonds would
Splat and finds ore in the beauty of
this new world they've discovered
everything about the mission to save the
Pando plant starts to make him uneasy
towards the end of the movie It's
revealed to search her and Ethan exactly
how wrong they are solidifying one of
the main themes of strange world in the
process after a classic fathers and
fight Ethan runs off the Airship and
Searcher follows eventually the two
discover themselves in a location Jaeger
was trying to reach all along on the
other side of the mountains it's here
that they discover their Planet as a
literal living being sadly the being
that avalonia sits atop is dying and
specifically it is being killed by the
avalonians harvesting the Pando plans
for their energy this twist turns a
story that was already about the
environment into a full-on metaphor for
the climate change crisis facing our
planet Strange World literally makes
this planet a living breathing creature
in order to communicate the idea to his
younger audience that the planet is
alive and can be harmed in the end
strange world is about learning to fix
our mistakes but also about making
sacrifices in order to adjust to a new
healthier world
after the story wraps up the audience is
transported to one year later in a Flash
Forward a voiceover from Ethan reveals
what happens to avalonia following the
events of strange world in the epilogue
Ethan talks about how the last year has
been incredibly difficult but that
everyone has proven just how resilient
they are considering the fact that
strange world is being released at the
tail end of the covid-19 pandemic is
hard not to think that Ethan's sentiment
might have a deeper meaning strange
world is far from a throwaway animation
and instead contains a crucial subtext
about climate change that mainly adults
and older teens will pick up on but
beyond that Ethan's talk of resilience
appears to reference a pandemic in
particular this moment serves as a
rallying cry for all the viewers who
fought through a hard year but must
continue doing the work to enact change
ultimately this call to action as the
overarching theme of strange world with
a movie asking viewers to care for the
planet before it's too late
[Music]